[Music]
so everyone uh it's exciting to be here
day one of my gym residency uh here at
St Lucia's Club in 2022
um excited to be here and uh as my first
lecture of the Grand Master Choice I'm
going to go over some of the
critical yet
come I mean conceivably easy to
understand moments of the match between
sparsky and Fisher Fisher's basket
1972 match of the century
we are at the 50 years anniversary of
this event
first the result it was seven to three
for Fisher and 11 draws so that if you
do the math it's seven plus five and a
half 12 and a half to
uh what eight and what plus four eight
and a half yeah
and it's one of the
one of the most crushing World
Championship matches in the modern
history of chess
uh honestly we haven't had that since
kaspora short enough recently we had
Carlson against the nepomyachi so
and the stories itself is fascinating so
I think Fisher was not going to show up
for quite some time they were they were
debating back and forth
uh Henry Kissinger called him I guess
asked him to sign up for his country
doing his
patriotic Duty anyways back and forth
here we have
Fisher and Reykjavik played a match with
with the [ __ ] game one
uh
11th of
July
to 1972.
50 years and how many months and
no no it's just listen less than a month
like 20 20
89 days something like that kind of
yeah I'm into this kind of details thing
sorry for the lack of brevity so
um all right so here
we have game one there is not much to
talk about the game one except for one
moment and uh it appears that Joseph
just wants to show that uh he can skip
he can he can he can avoid losing to
Fisher the result between the two
players within this match was plus two
for spaski with two wins and a draw or I
don't know two wins or two draws if my
memory helps but I'm sure two wins then
the draw is correct one draw at the
Olympia the one win at the Olympia first
basket and another win at the theater
cup
so they played it on
a very simple uh ragozine
and uh it's very funny that this opening
got out of
mainstream for a long time
and Fisher was the only world champion
was playing until the modern chess with
with the with the engines it
it became more popular so another
uh
evidence another another uh reason why
we could believe that fisher was way
ahead of his time the way he was playing
chess at the time
so this this bishop D3 C5
so spaski did not go for the main line
and where usually they they don't they
do not play the move E3 they bring the
bishop out and that's the main line here
goes in
and after this move I'm just going to
mention that there are so many moves
black can play H6 black can play now
blackmail usually plays at six here but
also can play them move Queen to A4
check
uh giving a check here attacking the
king and the bishop but then Blacklist
Knight C6 blocking the chick and
defending the bishop and this is the
most topical line
nowadays
in this opening
um
there's a lot going on here
no need to cover it all the way we're
talking about Fisher sparsky so just
mentioning that this is the mainstream
today
so Spacek transposes into a well-known
Labyrinth of nimso Indian the players
making normal moves and Fisher plays
above Bishop A5 which is also becoming
pretty popular well I was pretty popular
but it's
it was considered dubious for some time
but nowadays we also thanks to the
engines we know that it's quite playable
some might think that you can take on C5
here but then take on C3 for for uh for
black and then attacking these pawns
with the queen A5 or queen E7
or dtec C4 then Queen A5 so basically
this queen A5 attacks these two pawns
both at the same time
or queen E7 attacking the spawn besides
this double Pawns in the long run are
weak and you always can attack them and
and uh
black will have enough compensation as
they put it
for Department that is is lost so
don't worry Fisher did not blunder upon
spaski wasn't looking for complications
he went for 92.
and after Fisher liquid is with DTX C4
this bishop D6 he decides that okay
um
I'm okay with the draw and I place the
move DTX C5
which actually I think if you put an
engine on and this is the only time I'm
going to do that because in this lecture
I'm not supposed to do that but I wonder
oh actually can I have can I have a
key bit sir
just adding a lecture for adding a chess
engine for a second as you can see it
actually appears to be the best move so
it's not only a way to play for the draw
it's just the best move of the of the
board at this moment
uh so [ __ ] played the solid he takes
C5 because after the move detects C5
Queen takes D1 Rook takes D1 Bishop
takes C5
so the power structure is completely
symmetrical you see that okay except for
the pawn on A3 correct does that make
sense
um and that's of course the tempo when
you move B4 Bishop here Bishop B2 if we
just look at this so we have two versus
two here
four versus four these there's no
breakthrough Pawn breakthrough because
it's symmetrical everything is just
blocks just you know they're just in
front of each other
so um
but if you think about development white
has developed one two three four five
pieces black has double one two three
now it is not a big deal here
because
um
because a black is quick to get things
pieces to the game and uh it's not it's
not it's not it's not a problem that
white cannot pose any problem to a
Black's position because uh he doesn't
have an immediate attack
um
um
Fisher played Bishop D7
uh especially complete his development
Rook fd8 Knight D4 so Spacek is playing
really unambitious trading pieces
whereas I mean he could play something
else maybe bring the king to the center
trying to play with
for a space like moving the Knight and
play F4 E4 E5 something like that
because he has a bit ahead in
development but he plays completely on
ambitious game one he just wants to draw
capture capture
he says no to everything Fisher is
trying to complicate the game he trace
the pieces capture capture
the king's marching toward the center
same
then he trace the Rooks
F6 was played
by Fisher is trying to play E5 and then
securing this this Square for the king
really I don't see the move F6 what does
he do really but Fisher played it
anyways he could just play King E8 or
Knight c395 anyway this is extremely dry
there's nothing happening here there's
not many ear threats or something
F6
Knight A5
96 King D3
Bishop d8 is dismissing this Knight
otherwise if the Knight doesn't move he
just takes on A5 and the pawns are
doubled this Knight is also defending
this of course this is all well
protected I'm going to close this
because there's one question I want to
ask you
and then Knight C4 cat Bishop Bishop C7
capture capture and then
B5
and here comes the the famous moment
have you seen this one before yeah
yeah he took on H2 and for those who are
watching this if you haven't seen it uh
pause for a second and think about why
this is so bad and there's not much to
talk about it that is very simple I hope
you
paused and uh and get back to this
moment
and uh the point is to move uh G3 just
blocks the Bishop from going out
and The Bishop's trapped
um he tries to free the free the bishop
with this move H5
and no it's not happening
so The Bishop's gone so white is up a
voice up a piece now then game is quite
easy
and spaski plays it with uh
with a good level of technique
that is expected from a world champion
right I mean after all he was the world
champion
F5 and then goes King there he does he's
not afraid of this E5 F4 because his
Bishop controls is a square and if he
goes all the way winning the spawn and
then heading this way so I'm gonna just
throw some arrows
he's fast because like
uh Fisher but let's just make moves to
see that
not to mention I can go back but let's
just see what happens if I go here
obviously I have the counter play over
here so I could have been wrong I mean
probably he has this move now I need to
draw
but
but if he goes
if he goes uh
this way then
I'm heading this way I'm winning a spawn
but anyways I could go back
after King G5
and now I win this pass quite easily
like if he goes here just Bishop G1 and
black is this looks wrong
what's that oh sorry
thank you
sorry about that sorry so I'm gonna go
back again just
are we good now
okay sorry about that so if E5 King G5
F4 capture capture I was talking to the
king G6 is a flam but then black has a
counter against winning this Pawn on A4
so instead I'm talking about the move um
F4
sorry I mean
after F4 here
we go back King G4
and now the spawn is gone because black
is in six one and if he goes here
just uh
I don't know
Bishop here King here Bishop here
F3 King G5 and he's again six one
so the good thing about having the extra
Bishop for for space is that he could
lose as many 10 people with the bishop
as he wants and the bishop goes around
so they're basically are playing kind of
a Checkers here
so yeah and uh anyways he played F4 and
eventually
the game in uh
the game was won by uh
hello welcome hello going well how are
you good welcome
so and then yeah and then
the end here we are game was over all
right
nothing so Grand about this one
uh just because we're covering features
basket and 50th anniversary
uh so this was just how it started well
the next one doesn't have much of a
anyways the point is that there's no
move on the right side you don't see
them but
but the thing is this is game two
wearing Fisher didn't show up because of
the problems with the camera so that's
2-0 now for for his Pass key so I'm
gonna close this
all right so now we get to this game
game three and this has a very important
this has a very this has a great deal of
value in the in the history of this
match and everything because we're now
here Spas gas plus three against not
cluster in the match but plus three in
their lifetime matches never lost a
single game to to Fisher and then we
have this game honestly since we're
talking about this and his 50th
anniversary and we have to say all the
positive things I also want to look at
this game it doesn't
represent the world championship
material never I mean it's obvious that
the two players are under immense stress
immense pressure
but uh we should come up with with an
idea that uh it became popular and that
makes benoni even now this playable
although the engines are saying plus one
or something for uh for for white all
the time so we have benoni
and uh you know spascal is one of the
most first level world champions and
Fisher equally could play all kinds of
openings so
that kind of makes them quite unique
until Magnus basically
it's used basketball player is a
classical idea
and here nowadays the move A4 is more
more popular
you save the Queen's move because if he
wants to go Knight E5 for the very same
reason in this game he played Queen C2
and then buddy Fisher play
nine to H5 yes yes the 95 moment the
famous 95 moment
where he wants to go to F4 and he's okay
if he captures so
you see now we look at it with the
engines oh look oh duh but look this is
1972.
Fisher does not have a coach I mean yes
Lombardi was there but I I wonder if
nobody could do really much for him
except just checking the basics of his
um his uh
at Jordan games
so this is probably home cooked by by
Fisher and I don't I don't know if it
was played before Fisher I'm sure he was
but thinking that this is playable and
you have the
um courage to play in a world
championship match yeah that is that is
something
yep it was
so um and and uh spaska's reaction
wasn't
really fantastic so you capture capture
play Knight C4 Knight E5 that's good not
E3 so this was known I think Patricia
has already done this a few times before
at some point ended up sacrificing some
book for this bishop and put the Knight
on F5 I think I have it in my in my
files where I teach exchange sacrifice
and future was so big on that
um so he played the move Queen H4
and I don't like the smooth Bishop that
you played by by by
sparsky because what does he even do
it doesn't do anything
it doesn't do anything
so
um I analyze this move F3 and this is
me talking to the engine so these are
not all engine move me talking to the
engine
so I I made this move as white against
engines move as black
so
F5 because I'm stepping Knight G4 now F3
because next move Fisher was going to
play energy for which he did in this
game
so
so uh in this moment I mean F5 makes
makes sense otherwise I'm just going to
play now I want to do this right right
now that the bishop has somewhere to go
yeah but you stop the G4 intrusion yep
yeah so I looked at F5 which kind of
creates a lot of uh
I would say chaos
and then King H1 I'm just getting out of
the way
for those who are
a little bit new to chess I'm sorry
who are will watch Us online but this is
a very important moment in this match so
we have to talk about it so um the move
is just purely prophylactics because of
all these night jumps and Bishop the
Knight jumps and the bishop coming
so just stopping the threads F4 Knight
F5 attacking the Queen the Knight is
attacking the queen so the bishop must
take the the Knight on F5 takes back
Knight C4 Knight E4 B5
and must defend the Knight on C4
A4 attacking the pawn on B5
A6 and then can you tell what can what
do maybe I should give you a few minutes
this is the best moment for those who
are just what's the rating guys by the
way
yeah
okay
1200 okay so it would be hard for you 42
000 you you could I mean if I give you
five minutes yes but I cannot give you
five minutes we don't have that much
time but I'll give you a couple of
minutes to think about it
what does Y2 here
uh it's not tactics it's not tactics
what's your move
uh I mean okay I was just looking a
little
bit
and when I started that's why with G3
then Rook takes and then engine claims
that this is very this is a very strong
attack so for what's your name sorry
your name is uh Kevin and Matt so Matt
so the idea is that I want to open the
Rook will open up to this King and then
the bishop comes here and the Queen on
H4 is quite uncomfortable
and it's not only for he's an absolute
monster and this this guy is more of a
okay I have to change the colors
actually and this side on C4 is then
like a Cookie Monster right this one it
does look like a Cookie Monster to you
Maybe
so yeah so this is the idea and uh and
uh yeah and this Knight can never go to
E3 just to give you an idea why
because capture capture and then I have
this move F6 now
and if you captured in G3 and then The
Bishop's gone because you see Matt the
queen can cannot defend the bishop on F6
the queen whatever the ghost the
ninetics F6 chickens game over so that's
that's why it cannot do that so F3 so
I'm asking too much from the world
champion to find a movie of three
preventive against Knight G4 four
Champions are champions of prophylactics
that's what distinguishes GMS from iems
and world champions from anyone they can
they can smell this kind of threats from
afar
so it just says [ __ ] wasn't himself
the whole Aura the whole Euphoria of
world championship against an American
has has taken him by I don't know
he wasn't himself but but Fisher was at
his at his best so Bishop teach you
nachi for you Fisher makes the most out
of his chances Bishop for Queen F6
G3 again this is not the world
championship move you have to go World
Championship move you have to go back
Bishop G3 F4 you have to you cannot just
concede weaknesses on light squares oh
sorry
when your opponent has a light Square
Bishop
so Fisher plays Bishop D7 running for
the B Pawn
this and very strong move B6 because he
wants not to go a6b5 so good for Matt
and those who are watching live and
online
if I go A6 there's A5
I have a hard time playing the idea B5
so that's called proflex by playing the
move B6 and that's what
that's what shows that you know Fisher
was himself and that's what makes it
very important
rookie one A6 rookie 2 B5 and then
Fisher was executing his plans he was
fast and he was merciless
sir rookie there Queen G6 pinning it's
not exactly a pinning but I'm just this
is a good x-ray to have because end
games are always good for us because we
have two Bishops and already an
established majority right
where what is Bishop smoothly covering
makes sense Matt are we good okay
so please B3 spec but already you can
feel that he's shaking so then what what
can Fisher do
a couple of minutes I'm giving a couple
of minutes
eventually you want to do that but again
preparation and prophylactics think like
a world champion
so Kevin you want to play before you
want to you want to exploit E4 score
that's your that's your main plan right
yeah
yeah so how do you do that
no if I go A5 I'm I'm hanging at this
point
if I wait for
me
no I you don't want to give up this guy
this guy is is this guy is uh you're a
sniper for the for that for that for
that majority here you want to explore
E4 you first prepare it
so [ __ ] is trying to stop the the
pawns from coming forward because now
Fisher's threatening B4 Bishop to B5 you
see this is his threat now
and then before now
so his plans to play rookie eight and
then before and then F5 that's and then
the whole thing
uh
I mean he just opens I mean just the
wise Position will be left I mean
everything is wide open the Bishops are
very strong and then once everything
gets traded off this this pawns once
this Pawn is here once once this oops
sorry
uh
once the spawn gets to this square if I
get to play oops what's this this is a
very sensitive Mouse you have an
assignment
no it's good I'm just kidding F5 a trade
and then then once the special goes
around then oops it's gonna be very
dangerous if I get all the imagine all
the major pieces going off the board
that trade the bishop is behind the
point that's where we came over
complicated things and before but now
that policy for is a monster sitting
there people comes to E8 and now white
is complete tied down but for you Matt
we're not going to take on C3 you cash
out when you know it's time for so we
don't we don't rush into cash out right
um in chess when I teach chess and to
the people who are like my age a little
bit older or whatever they like
financial terms I would just say uh
then you have when you have an adventure
without counter play it's like your IRA
you don't capture your IRA
that's what it is an advantage without
the counter play is your IRA don't touch
it
this H5 back Improvement
diversify reinvest you just keep going
forward okay there okay he's not finding
a plan that's fine okay it's time to
cash out
you go around you see okay your
portfolio doesn't grow okay it's time to
cash out
and it's a good time to cash out because
after all these trades now now after the
cash it's time to invest in something
else now you see all of a sudden I'm in
good shape and after Bishop H6 Queen
back here
depose the bishop
Queen B1 pinning it can get fun and
Bishop and now
if only white could play the move Bishop
B2 we were the one who was going to be
in trouble right
but this bishop is luckily pinned and
now we are the one who are going to
exploit all these squares
oh
all of them
so
game continued King E2 Queen E4 check
Queen E3 Queen C2 check
Queen D2 Queen B3 Queen D4 and Bishop D3
check and the mate will follow very soon
because after they move Queen to King to
E1 Queen C2 and I'm threatening both
mate
and this capture
uh I could also take the pawn on before
but I I mean this makes more sense to me
because I want to Checkmate here oh yes
Queen E3 now so wait a second I can't
take the pawn
is really the only move oh wait because
now he doesn't okay this is mate because
he doesn't have this one yeah yeah okay
okay
I'm so tired from my trip from back from
California playing 90 round tournament
so
instead of covering okay
also the funny thing is that I've I
never went be beyond the movie uh Beyond
this movie in the game I never I it's
the first time I went beyond this game
so I looked at this game up to this
point like maybe 100 times but I've
never gone through all of the all of the
news before
because it was like oh why black is
winning
so I've never actually spent time
looking at it okay wasn't the greatest
game but it was the pivotal moment it
was the pivoting moment for Fisher
because he won his first game ever
against the world champion
and speaking of the rating difference I
mean look at this oh you don't see it
there but at the time Fischer was 27.85
and
and spasco's high 2600 that's like
almost 100 points rating difference
that's how the matches are now what it
is between Carlson and his opponents
basically
the only difference is that cousin is
also the World Champ the world champion
which makes it even harder for his
opponents to play against him
um
and yeah that was uh that was the first
win this is the game The Equalizer game
for game five they drew the game four so
this is The Equalizer
and here Fisher played this famous idea
of Knight G6 which now it is even the
engines on the high steps they show that
because this shuts down the two Bishops
here it's a kind of advanced concept
and uh after capture capture
it looks it looks
it looks really good
and but it really is not and A5 is
actually not that accurate played by
Fisher but that's okay
it seems that white has a past Pawn
a particular past spawn and two Bishops
and that
to anyone you just say someone has that
you would say oh that's fantastic and
what has nothing here because they're
very pawns are the 16 the very same
Bishops and actually this black triangle
pawns after G5 9594 gives black a
counter play so it's more convenient to
plays as black than as white
anyways a long game goes along and then
actually
to pass this credit he maintained the
balance for quite some time
and it was balanced until now when he
blundered Queen C2 which loses to what
time we cannot answer that
A4
deflection false so another reason that
how much pressure was on a sparsky
playing this match
I think Queen E3 was a draw Queen B1 was
a draw he has so many moves and then
this blunder and I think
this is my opinion I'm not an expert on
official's basket match I'm just a chess
player okay Grandmaster have some life
experience playing this game and it's
it's a very difficult game it's a lot of
psychological and mental capacity it
takes to to play good chess and I think
that was this was a defining moment I
think if spaska was not going to make
this blunder In This Moment
it would have been a completely
different match it would have not been
the walk in the park officially got from
this point on
it it just yeah it just collapsed here
I'm a fish basket was gone from here he
could see this part from here and there
but he was in he was so inconsistent he
couldn't keep up with the game and we
were just like always something missing
in his calculation and I think this was
it if he had if he had kept this game if
he hadn't blonde in this moment
I would say still Fisher was going to
win the match because he was a stronger
player but it would have been a hell of
a match
which we probably would have enjoyed
more now talking about it but hey the
history is already written so
it's it's the good thing is that we
cannot rewrite it
uh okay and now comes the final game
that I've prepared for you
and I call this the gem of the match
which is game six Fisher versus the
spaski and I love this and I use this to
to teach players from 1000 to 2200 and I
love the clarity and simplicity of the
Fishers play shows us reminds us of old
times capablanca and uh and it's so sad
when I was looking at this game with an
engine oh my God like every move is
inaccurate everything here and there
okay it's a different time now but but
when I was a kid I looked at it and it
was the first time let me think about it
I was I'm talking 24 years ago first
time I saw this I was 13 already too
late but okay
back in my
back in my back in where where I'm from
which is Iran
there weren't so many there were so many
chess books there so chess was banned
for a long time
so we only heard of Fisher I had I even
hadn't seen a photo official until I was
10.
so C4 is six Knights F3 D5 D4 Knight F6
Knight C3
Bishop E7 and we have a Queen's Gambit
where uh White wants exert pressure in
the center black is extremely solid
everything is very well protected but
black lacks one thing which is what Matt
can you tell black is behind in one
thing one of the key Concepts in the
opening which is what
space
this bishop is stuck here yeah that's
the problem so the four golden rules
Matt King safety development space and
center and material these are the four
things you want to look after in the in
the opening the first 15 moves and I
don't have enough space but other than
that everything else black is just fine
so it goes at six Bishop drops back B6
now we have
it's a tmb
a tmb
so tmb or TBM some people call it it's
called Target
system of the Queen's Gambit mostly
people refer to the starter cover but
it's actually all three guys have
contributed to this opening I would say
equally but Toyota cover was number one
so the idea is that I want to
put my put my pressure on the long
diagonal and place C5 and treat
everything and then my problems are gone
the setback is that
um
I'm literally becoming my structure and
as you will see
um nowadays this is considered perfectly
fine for black easy easy equality and
actually sparsky achieved it but
remember
we have a [ __ ] playing game six
rattled by his blunder in game five
so that's the hard thing to to deal with
it takes text takes
takes number seven
C1
let's pass this place just fine there's
C5 he pins it that's okay looks C8 and
then Fischer begins his uh
uh usual practical approach playing
Bishop B5 he's trying to kind of just
being in really
annoying opponent by just say okay you
want to play 97 play 97 but I'm going to
play D takes C5 and then maybe I take
your knight on D7 I put more pressure on
your Pawns
depressed at night
the idea is if he goes Knight D7 he
wants maybe to Castle and at some point
take it
the thing is it really does nothing so
Fisher play specifically this Fisher
took and castle
then spaski played just fine player with
K7 perfectly fine move
he gets out of the pin we see because
the bishop In This Moment The Rook is
pin if I take the bishop
then The Rook is gone so now he's
unpinned the bishop must move which he
did
and then this basket broad United again
that's perfectly fine too and then here
Fisher played Knight D4 that this must
have really thrown off uh spassky
because according to the engines is not
a big deal
yeah
it's starting to take the bishop and
play that position and actually
spasky really
fell for the idea because he took it
very seriously because if he takes you
can take back with the queen so fine I
mean yeah white has some pressure on V5
after that because the bishop can go to
F3 and there but you have ample defense
because your queen defense here so you
can go here and Knight goes here you
have defense too you are not hopeless
basically here right but then
sparsky does the impossible and just
walks into it walks into what gives
Fisher a direct line which Fisher and
direct plan he's like two three thousand
like he can't be he can't be as strong
as Magnus Carlson
with direct plant Fisher was really like
modern players
so ghost Queen f8
we take but now you see the pawn left
the king safety so it's like the king
had the castle and now he has a shack
it's not it's not it's not the same
thing
and now we're going to even more exploit
because now the light scores are weak
because this Pawn is is possible to
attack it the spawn is possible to
attack it we're going to talk about
denying this Pawn is already a Target
so I have too many squares to tack and
now comes to my favorite move of the
match what did you do here Fisher
go ahead
that's that's exactly right exactly he
goes E4 and if he goes D takes E4 then
he goes just Rook C4 Queen E3 and then
you see if he goes like this move
then this way I'm gonna win this guy
maybe or even maybe just Queen H3 or
Bishop C4 I win this guy then I go for
this guy and this guy see these pawns
are all become targets so uh but he
still had to do that [ __ ] D4 now I
get to play F4 and Bishop C4 so I get an
attack even at no cost
so basically official is playing with it
with the house money
I like that kind of game I mean if you
have any game Ben I mean I'll be glad to
join but playing with house money
right okay
Queen Seven E5 and now I have a fixed
Target here and uh and a restricted
Knight so that's great so Fisher is
doing his job Bishop C4 King h8
targeting
then I equals to f8 is Pass Key then it
goes B3
getting rid of the pressure A5
F5
and the attack is now rolling
e takes F5
Rook takes F5
Knight H7
okay now how do we continue our attack
simply
double up yeah
28 and what do we do next
no because there's Knight G5 so I have
to get my queen out of the way
Queen G3 why when I go with the pawn to
H4 is tricking this this Knight and then
I'm preparing the move
Rook F7
there H4
yeah H4 Rook bb7 B6 now pinning the pawn
there now he wants to go to F7 so in
case of capture he takes me the pawn
there and the pawn is one step closer to
to queening
uh
xc7
Queen E5
domination I'm just dominating the board
Rook F7 is coming so also Fisher is like
now acting like a cat playing with the
with the prey
and that's that's a that's a fun kind of
languages actually I'm telling you it's
not only Fisher any any GM I know a
strong GM they like to play around when
they have Advantage because it's
psychologically shatters your opponent
you know you you have pressure and you
just make it move and it doesn't do
anything immediately but your opponent
has nothing to do about it and so
so um
uh they say sometimes the mice
die before the cat kills them because
they become so hopeless they just give
up on the idea of that they can they can
get out of the hand of the cat so they
they basically die to the idea I mean I
don't know it is not science if we've
proven but it's it's a myth that people
talk about
so and because I'm a cat lover I have a
cat so I I tend to believe that my cat
is that smart so
so Queen E8 A4 I see
a cat plays the mouse it doesn't it
doesn't do anything
but you just make shows his opponent how
hopeless he is Queen Diego one F2
Queen E8 Rook view F3 this is
amazing just passing I think he's trying
to get to the move 40.
because they could have drawn and he
could see the win at the end of the uh
go he would go home and because in those
days they would join the games so he
could go home and just check check the
actual win
there Bishop D3
targeting the Knight Queen E8
Queen goes to E4 now he's he's planning
on playing them playing the X-ray so if
he goes back to kicks his six years
rookie five wins the game because I I'm
attacking H7 for checkmate and the other
one is I'm double attacking The Rook on
E6 and that's game over
Knight goes to F6 Fisher takes capture
Rook F6
uh
spaska plays King G8
Fisher goes Bishop C4 again making sure
this Rook doesn't move because of E7
check intercepting and then Rook f8
finished
king h8 and queen F4 this is move 41 I
think
this is the move that fisher I don't
know if he played the move or he put it
the ceiling I don't know I've never
played in a Jordan game have you played
a game with games with adjournments
have you played games with adjournments
yeah
yeah so I don't know if he sealed they
used to seal them if they would write it
down and they couldn't say Yeah in an
envelope yeah
yeah so I don't know if it was he played
at the board and then specifically
instead his move or whatever I don't
exactly know
and then uh
and anyways here I think Spacek just
resigned
uh
and uh yeah and this is when game six
went Fisher took the lead and then
everything else was
is history he just cruised through it
winning with seven over three
and uh
and we have
we have 50 years
anniversary coming up
which is already has been it has
happened already so check out chess uh
World Chess Hall of Fame and website
which is worldchess hof.org for more
upcoming events as part of this new
exhibition the exhibition will be on
view until April 30th of next year 2023
thank you